ouais si jamel
non
ça va et vous est-ce que tu connais ça
cya
g
un jour j'ai envoyé un texto à jamel
disant tu connais sont ils ont répandu
le connard ça fait un an je danse dessus
c'est vrai que ça fait longtemps ça tu
viens tu parce que tu débarques dans le
showbiz voilà c'est fait pour ça ça va
et toi
ouais bien ça avec le move est là ou
quoi chez kaboul la creuse jour
spectacle je suis arrivé up direct pour
vous pour rejoindre la petite troupe
ça s'est passé comment extraordinaire
les gens debout tout nu mais j'étais de
l'argent vont bien nous voir non
extraordinaire moi je kiffe raymond
chiche je me promène les gens sont
contents je suis ravi d'en c'est un
spectacle qui va beaucoup plus politique
donc que le premier non il ya plus de
fonds gd plus c'est vrai les gens ont
raison il s'aperçoit tout doucement que
j'ai une conscience politique chez une
conscience politique des plus beaux
jours de ma naissance je suis engagée
depuis 18 jours 75 et jusqu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui à des choses tellement
tellement visible tellement flagrant de
ne pas faire au combat pour faire
autrement que d'en parler de les
dénoncer et et moi mon stack je le fait
qu'en parler sur scène quoi ça reste
encore un petit engagement mais c'est
drôle en même temps c'est pas une
dénonciation agressive
non je sais rien faire d'autre moi c'est
la seule manière de m'exprimer 18 juin
c'est bien comme ça il est né le jour de
l'appel du général
c'est fou - là tu en as une question de
philippe de gaulle tient à ce que serge
est ce qu'on peut envoyer parce que
c'est que c'est ton pote comme la galère
voir bien sûr fugier et c'est ce qui m'a
dit j'ai redit géré déjeuner avec lui il
dit et ivry j'ai la casse est quand même
qu est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui m'a dit
jamel en arabe je suis bien pour lui
qu'il ait pas dit
donc j'ai dit d'abord on va faire
traduire qu'est ce que vous lui donnez
là qu'est ce que j'avais dit après un
truc très sympa très sympa mais là il va
te parler parce qu'ils pouvaient pas
t'attendre avec plaisir serge magnéto si
j'ai une question à lui poser
on regarde on regardera plus diffusera
tout à l'heure non parce que il a tout
le succès que son talent mériterait et
c'est très bien ainsi car c'est un homme
d'esprit monsieur aperçu qu'il avait
beaucoup d'esprit ça lui fera plaisir
ah oui par exemple quand il m'a dit à
moi je débarque à roissy charles de
gaulle qu'est ce que vous devez toucher
comme le droit d'auteur et finira le
libellé de cette émission malades et des
familles de goumois jeu l'équipe je les
connais par coeur je connais tous leurs
trucs je vais parcours il faut gta
j'étais sur les ronds-points gto changé
à l'aéroport je connais tous vos sites
jeu mais de gaulle lacharrière continuer
ouais pratiquement moi j g j'aime bien
le pape a aussi changé il a fait des
trous balourds vous pas oublié il a
quand même mis aux galères bon nombre de
tirailleurs marocains sénégalais qui
noie et il a quand même inventé le
deuxième bureau il a quand même interdit
ces gens de défiler le jour de la
victoire sur les champs-elysées et il a
quand même frustré bon nombre de
d'immigrés que tu es venu pour aider la
mère patrie
donc la famille de vol je viens bien
mais pour prendre l'avion ça va pas trop
chaud
toi tu peux aussi jouer tes traits chez
moi j'ai moi j'aime une doudoune suis
fou ça va du tablier comme elle sait
qu'elle va se marier
c'est pour ça pichette catastrophe avec
qui à david david je voulais c'est pas
vrai c'est bien ça n'arrête pas ses amis
avec galles c'est fini rigade gaz
prenant pas gad
c'est pas parce que je m'étais dit s'ils
ne leur est en tournée non parce qu'on
se connaît bien avec d'azur ça n'a rien
à voir
vacances ont tourné par exemple fois je
regardais un documentaire sur zain fall
qui était en tournée aux états unis
le mec il est une mercedes et lui il
conduit sa mercedes ou soit contournée
taqwa 50 personnes avec toi on est 30
ouais mais je conçois pas la tourner
différemment je suis jour tout seul dans
sa chambre d'hôtel et tout seul la tête
dans sa petite voiture aussi mercedes
qu'elle soit c'est pas intéressant pour
y aller en bus à 30
apple a mis un peu le rolling stones au
concert nous non mais on le serait pas
ce que tu veux si tu j'ai fait des
tournées c'est génial c'est le meilleur
moment d'amis et bouleaux prévalu même
date
ce serait ridicule mais c'est un nom
avant raconte t elle faisait rien moi je
suis à venir la moitié algérien moitié
marocain moitié français moitié cela
vous moitié pleine crise on chez moi
aussi n'empêche je suis je suis je suis
où je suis d'arabie c'est un enfant du
soleil et où ils ont fait un truc sur le
départ de jerry en 62 kg s'est alors vu
pareille pourtant l'offre c'est bourré
de jean le loeuff que tu as acheté à
jamais j'ai pas acheté un jeu les loups
mais c'est vrai que il est plein tout
temps il ya beaucoup de mètres carrés
donc j'ai encore une fois
saint-germain-des-prés ça vaut la peine
d'être vécue si ces vécus et qu'elle
fait tout d'ailleurs je te jure ses
potes qui débarque guy béart juliette
gréco c'est plutôt cela mais si nous
sinon les cerveaux on dirait la mjc de
mantes ermont appartement j'en suis très
heureux ce jardin avec des fois je
retrouve dans le frigo il faisait 2
minutes
c'est passé c'est la d anthony désolé
mais on sera là c'est un vrai qu'il n'a
pas le temps d'en profiter sur la route
là c'est jusqu'à j'ai regardé t sur la
haute jusqu'à mi décembre
ouais mais c'est un vrai qui je toujours
c'est ce que je préfère faire
j'ai agi en rapport avec le public en
plus et les gens sont contents
d'accueillir je prends un malin plaisir
à y aller je kiffe
d'ailleurs je veux remercier tous les
gens qui sont dépassés je sens qu'on
fait au montage non
qu'est ce qu'elle est devenue c'est
devenu un vrai sex symbol nom depuis que
tu as du succès non non pas tant il pas
il paraît que quand tu rome en tâchant
de déployer des filles qui t'attendent
ça m'arrivait une ou deux fois mais si
tu sais ce que c'est quoi ces sapins la
routine c'est non non non non non mais
c'est vrai que que depuis que je touche
jsf c'est plus facile
ouais ouais ouais mais j'ai aucun
problème j'assume pleinement hochtief
c'est extraordinaire les départs en cela
ils vont très bien et moi je ne vaux
jours d'ailleurs savais que je les dois
way méditer des rats bonjour intérêts
leur descente
dishonored et sonore des sceaux c'est
bien un truc génial tu as dit chez moi
l'homme que je respecte le plus c'est ma
mère et tu as dit elle avait cette gosse
et elle a réussi à nous faire croire
qu'on n'était pas pauvre je trouve ça
génial
à dessein
c'est vrai j'ai je joue mon logis une
enfance est super heureuse la mère a
toujours fait en sorte on ait besoin de
rien
aie aie aie aie quand des fois il n'y
avait pas grand chose à manger ne vous
et du pain et du thé nous et nous
expliquer qu'elle n'avait pas le temps
de faire à manger donc le pari noter
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on préférait
robot la veille on dit et j'aurais pu
passer le témoin le c'est un être
incroyable à elle été fournis chez
bouygues a faisait le ménage elle était
heureuse comme tout elle courber
l'échiné a été d'accord avec tout non
parce que ma mère comme comme beaucoup
de mal à travailler dur pour être pauvre
il s'agit d'un dock donc si elle savait
négligeable moi je les ai vus je l' ai
vécu et je peux pas l'oublier a plane
maman qui te sont dans les mêmes
conditions aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
manière là la chance de plus travaillé
et et attaque le piston le coq et de
palets trouver des ménages à faire
le temps des tracts en main comprend non
c'est bon elle avait traité fous toi
maintenant un aller aux bahamas en train
de bronzer dense et dynamique you back
chez accor comme ça ton père bon mon
père il est un peu plus un peu plus
comment dirais-je silk way we were l été
ils étaient ils étaient forcément
beaucoup plus dur mais c'est normal si
on habitait dans un quartier dur mon
père mon père il était dur mais était
d'une générosité incroyable je te jure
je me souviens d'un jour ont regardé une
publicité à la télévision qui disait
qu'avec 10 francs pour une nourrir toute
une famille au rwanda plus à la toucher
il a essayé d'envoyer toute ma famille
au rwanda moi je l'équipe en clair et
maquillés par exemple qu il voulait
jamais vous voulez pas deux fois
comédien il m'a toujours dit comédienne
c'est pour les [ __ ] et les immo
sexuelle digue du moratoire
baudis et au maroc il ya le ccp qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran pour envoyer
du pognon j'allais venir
moi j'ai toujours cette association qui
s'appelle l'heure joyeuse charih si tu
pouvais laisser l'adresse bien
évidemment sur l'écran elle définit le
regarder merci donc leur joyeuse qui
bien évidemment est ces sinistres et au
maroc al qassim à nous on a envie de
monter une opération avec les minimes
usine âme comme parages les solitaires
sollicité la semaine dernière il était
alité super partes envie c'est de monter
une opération pour aider les sinistrés
marocains et algériens des derniers
séismes via un concert où j'aimerais en
parler chez toi voilà donc si vous avez
des couvertures des cuillères des petits
suisses à en braille au maroc n'hésitez
pas on est preneur via leur joyeuse